told that the pm will relax covered
rules this week what's the science
behind that decision so the prime
minister is meeting the uh cabinet this
morning to just to look through and get
that balance right so we can see that uh
infections are coming down quite rapidly
the hospitalizations and deaths are
following as well they tend to lag
behind obviously the case numbers but
nonetheless you can see the trend within
that he'll be looking at the uh the best
advice possible but getting the balance
right because it's important that we
don't work uh and live under gov
government dictat for a moment longer
than as than as necessary to allow the
economy to recover to allow people to
get back to a sense of normality whilst
keeping people safe clearly
um will the changes come into effect
this week it's thursday friday isn't it
well that's that's for the prime
minister to announce later on i mean the
the regulations fall away um in about
three weeks time anyway uh 22nd of march
um brought it forward but the prime
minister will make his announcement
later on that that final decision hasn't
been taken okay um
as of then it looks as so even if you
test positive for covid you can you
don't have to self-isolate legally
uh so that will be well again that
decision will be taken uh later on so
we'll see the guidance around that but
uh but there will be a point when uh
all of this is falling away and so it
will come back to employers and
employees to make those decisions for
themselves but we'll see the guidance
that comes out later if a member of your
team next week say if this comes into
effect thursday friday next week if a
member of your team test positive for
covid would you tell them to stay at
home or come to work i mean i would say
that
like any illness frankly any
transmissible illness that you would say
uh you would say stay at home i mean
that's that's that you know if you had a
um a flu or something like that you'd
normally expect people to uh uh to take
the view but it will get down to
themselves or down to their employer
yeah that's the problem though isn't it
because you're a responsible employer
and you would say to your staff stay at
home and get well but if somebody's
working on a construction site or you
know an industry that is sensitive to
the number of staff that is there
they're going to feel under pressure to
go to work aren't they there there is
this and this is why we need to make
sure that we got really good guidance
for for employers but as i say there
will be there comes a time uh when when
the pandemic moves to more of an endemic
uh approach to uh to to covert in the
same way it flew when other other other
viruses um are treated and that's what
we've got to get back to but it's a fine
balance clearly and that's why cabinets
meeting this morning to go through the
science to go through that balance and
debate it and then obviously the prime
minister come before parliament to make
his announcement i understand but as as
a government minister you know as a
responsible employee as of today you
would say to somebody if they test
positive for kovit probably they should
stay at home so that they don't spread
it well as that's what the rules are i
mean as of today that's that that that
is the rules so we'll see next week but
we'll see what happens because i don't
even know when the date is that the
prime minister's gonna gonna hear it
because the decision hasn't been well
then uh well then we'll see what the
guidance is because as i say you can't
just um preempt what he's going to say
um because instead of all the rules
because the because yeah but it depends
on the date because the you can see that
the case numbers are coming down quite
significantly and if they carry on that
same electorate trajectory by the time
you get to the 22nd of march anyway
there will be a comparatively low rate
we're also dealing with um
a predominantly a variant that's a lot
milder than previous variants that
doesn't mean we can um uh be complacent
because what we are saying is that covid
hasn't gone away we're talking about
balance because we're still living with
covert yeah but what about those that
are most vulnerable in our society i
mean we know of a 95 year old lady who
lives in a castle you know and every
coveted restriction is taken to keep her
safe and she still contracted it she
won't and this will this won't happen
and she's still working but she's
working from home she's working uh
in isolation and that's exactly what
we're talking about learning to live
with kovid there is there comes a point
at some time when we're able to do that
we're able to give as many people back
there their freedoms as possible where
as many people to go about their
business and including uh the um
allowing the economy to recover but that
can't be at the expense of um of human
life and human wellbeing but we've got
to get that balance absolutely right but
if you're pressured by your employer to
go to work and you feel that you
shouldn't do you think that you know as
an employee you have a right to say no i
i don't want to spread this virus any
more than it is so i'm going to stay at
home yeah i mean look every employer has
a um a statutory duty to their employees
uh that is the case whether it's covered
whether it's any other disease or any
other ailment
i would encourage any employee that is
in that situation to approach acas to go
on the aks website to to um
and to follow through complaints through
that way because
employers no matter what it is have a
statutory duty
interestingly the um the unions a lot
the big three unions frontline doctors
uh all saying it's reckless uttar lunacy
and a super spread of free-for-all why
are they all wrong do you think i just
think it's it's it's a balance that i
was talking about and uh clearly the
unions uh and the other uh people that
you describe sit and it's you know they
have their balance in a different place
what we've always said is that we don't
want to have
uh
a moment longer than than we need to to
have government dictating how people run
their lives and what's the rationale
between about getting rid of free tests
because if we don't have free tests
people won't spend 35 quid on a box of
tests so we won't know if there are any
variants so what we're going to do is uh
either way we'll have a uh a level of
surveillance so we can check for uh
variants we can check to see what what's
going on but nonetheless you saw the
prime minister yesterday talking about
the fact that we can't continue
uh forevermore spending two billion
pounds a month on tests and if you think
what might that that two billion pounds
might go towards there's a lot of um
other uh backlogs in the nhs other
illnesses in the back uh and the nhs
that that money could otherwise go for
so for every person that's worried about
um a test there may be another person
that's worried about a cancer diagnosis
we know when the free tests are going uh
again no that's the prime minister will
make his statement later on talk to me
about what's happening with uh
ukraine are we closer or further away
from the invasion this morning than we
were yesterday well i'm not sure about
yesterday but there is the clear signs
that the um that there are um still um
troop movements on the border there's 7
000 more troops than uh than there were
um just a few days ago despite the
russians trying to signal the fact that
they were pulling away from the border
so there is a very very credible threat
and that's why
we've got to continue to be vigilant
we've got to continue to work with
ukraine and poland as uh as liz trust
the foreign secretary was doing uh just
this week um and it's important that
vladimir putin comes to the to
with that we engage in diplomatic um uh
approach to this because otherwise the
loss of life will be horrendous okay
i've seen some of these tanks with zed
written on the side do we know what that
is i don't know no i don't know either
lots of papers are reflecting on that
today i'm sure it'll become apparent um
in the fullness of time uh
how much do we have to take our hat off
to the soft diplomacy from president
macron who again was on the phone
yesterday to president putin for almost
two hours and it does look as though we
might potentially be heading towards
some sort of summit between the
americans and the russians as a direct
result of president macron getting
involved i think what's really good is
that all of the nato countries are
working closely together on this so that
they're all um playing leading roles in
making sure that we can defuse the
situation and hopefully therefore um
vladimir putin will step back from that
situation which as i say will be pretty
horrendous but he does seem to be doing
macron seems to be far more effective
than we are i just wondered why that was
no i'm not sure that's i'm not sure
that's right i think our foreign
secretary was you know i mean she was
snobbed when she went to moscow that's
because she's saying things that aren't
really
palatable to uh to the russian foreign
minister he doesn't things he doesn't
want to hear so uh
and getting much further than we do well
not necessarily i mean i think you have
to um say the good with that you have to
say the things that they don't want to
hear but then you have to give people a
way out that's that's just diplomacy um
that you never cut their their their
retreat and i hope therefore
um both of those approaches that come
together alongside the foreign
secretary's um work with poland and
ukraine and the prime minister being in
the security conference in munich will
actually bear fruit and vladimir putin
will come to see
that it's right to step back we know
that we've moved brits out of the
embassy for now in kiev moved them away
to a different part of the country we
also know that the americans have moved
their embassy staff from moscow for now
what are we going to do
uh i'm i'm not privy to those
conversations as a i'm a business
minister not a foreign office minister
so you know quite a lot about cyber
attacks though don't you how worried are
we about cyber well yes i mean that's a
real that's a real threat that's a real
threat i mean we've already seen
um uh a lot of work that's you know
they're worried about um cyber attacks
particularly in ukraine but that could
easily be a spread
further around europe and so these are
uh worried about how are we about them
in the uk well that we will be dealing
with those you know you know with with
the national cyber security center and
we're i'd push out um uh messages to any
business to make sure that they've got
um adequate protection whether it's
software and hardware
okay so we we haven't had any that we
need to worry about as of the last
couple of weeks when the attentions have
been heightened well there's nothing i
can i can report that you've been aware
of okay before i let you go i wanted to
ask you a couple of things firstly about
um her majesty and um how do we know how
she is i i don't know but i wish her um
all the best i do understand that she's
um still working at home and uh
uh and as we were talking earlier on
about about covet and what would happen
if you get it um it seems from what from
the reports i'm hearing that uh they're
uh relatively mild symptoms and i hope
that is exactly how it is until she's
better yeah as do we all 95 years young
she looks amazing still doesn't she tiny
tiny tiny put her in your pocket she's
amazing um just before we let you go
obviously the downing street party
question um if the pre-m gets a fixed
penalty notice should he stay on
i think there's not much moved on to be
fair since last time i spoke to you i
think what we want to do is see what
happens with the police action and the
police report see what happens with the
su great report and then look at it in
the round uh what we've got to be i've
always said i've treated a real high bar
to get rid of any prime minister what
about if they break the law because
i i think we just need to see it in the
round that's why i want to see
i want to see
or and or um misguided's parliament
misleads parliament
how can he stay well i think it
needs to i need to see context i
absolutely need to see context before i
make any any decision i don't think
that's right because uh
uh yeah but i understand this is i
understand this is one that's not
actually being investigated not by the
police the pictures that you were not by
the police so in terms of law breaking
that's not going to be um that's not
going to
reach the threshold of evidence but
nonetheless
that's what i mean about context that's
why i want to see the sugray report see
what happens see what the police find uh
and and then we can work through the um
you know have that conversation at that
point yeah but people singing happy
birthday in the cabinet room with your
interior designer there you know but
let's say that's what i want to see
you know i'm not gonna there's not a lot
i can add into a lot the the the the but
my question to start with was very
straightforward it wasn't about any of
the pictures that we're showing it was
about if the police have decided that
he's broken the law and he gets a fixed
penalty notice do we have a prime
minister in place who has broken the law
well i'm gonna i'm gonna wait until i
see context before i
you know really make any more judgment
on it